this video is sponsored by fabulous the
habit building and coaching app the
human heart is an incredible organ it
can pump 1.5 gallons of blood in one
minute beat up to 35 million times a
year and is practically impervious to
cancer because heart cells don't
replicate but like all things the heart
has its limits one of those limits is
how fast it can beat it's not something
you really think about you figure you
exercise or take stimulants and your
heart beats faster you'd assume if you
did more of this your heart would just
beat faster indefinitely but no there
are limits
alright there's a lot to unpack here so
i'll just jump to the ad fabulous is a
habit-building and coaching app that
breaks down healthy habits into small
tasks that you can easily complete every
day their techniques are backed by
decades of scientific research there's
two approaches to using this app
self-guided for habit building and
guided for habit coaching everyone has
different needs so fabulous gives you
the option to choose which approach is
right for you for myself i'm trying to
improve my focus and productivity i used
to use a list on my computer to keep
track of different tasks but with
fabulous i started writing my list down
in a notebook further suggestion and
that's been working better than my
digital solution it's also helping me
prioritize tasks in a way that gets them
done i can also opt out of getting
reminders so i can go at my own pace
fabulous makes it easy for anyone to
develop and stick to healthy habits
thanks to science-backed routines as a
result you'll feel healthier
accomplished and more productive start
building your ideal daily routine today
the first hundred people who click on
the link in the description will get
twenty five percent off their fabulous
purchase
to understand how fast a human heart can
be we first have to look at how a
heartbeat works your heart is a mass of
cardiac muscles hollow chambers and
conductive fibers cardiac muscle like
all skeletal muscle in the body
contracts due to electrical signaling
you want to grab an apple the nervous
system sends an impulse to the muscles
in your hand causing them to contract
and voila also pro-life tip this is why
when you get electrocuted you cannot let
go of the source that's shocking you
because your muscles are contracting
unlike your skeletal muscles which
receive impulses from the brain through
the nervous system your heart has its
own electrical network which is why it
can keep beating outside the body here's
how the heart's electrical system
produces a heartbeat an electrical
stimulus is first generated at the
sinoatrial node or sa node at the top of
the heart the signal moves down to the
av node and follows the conductive
fibers into four different chambers of
the heart called the right and left
atrium and the right and left ventricles
while the signal is traveling down the
fibers these chambers fill with blood
the atrium fills first the signal then
reaches the atriums causing cardiac
muscle to contract forcing blood into
the ventricles the signal then reaches
the ventricles causing them to contract
pumping blood into the lungs and the
body when this whole cycle has gone
through once it counts as a single
heartbeat it looks and sounds like this
[Music]
the rate at which a heart can beat is
limited by the heart's own electrical
system but why
well what's actually happening when the
electrical signal travels down the
cardiac fibers is it's causing sodium
channels on the cell to open sodium ions
rush into the cell generating an action
potential which delivers a stimulus to
the cell next to it opening its sodium
channels causing sodium to rush in
making another action potential on the
next cell this continues on until the
electrical stimulus reaches the muscle
causing a contraction once sodium ions
are inside the cardiac cell any
additional electric stimuli no matter
what will not be able to cause an action
potential on the cell until the sodium
ions are pumped out so while there's
still sodium in here no muscle
contraction of the heart can occur once
the cell is reset and sodium is pumped
out the stimulus can then cause another
action potential and therefore a heart
contraction this reset period is called
the absolute refractory period and is
what limits how fast your heart can beat
it's a physiological limit that ensures
your heart doesn't beat so fast that it
kills you with this reset mechanism in
place what's the maximum rate your heart
can beat well cardiologists seem to
agree that roughly 210 beats per minute
is a likely sustainable limit but then
again this is purely theoretical in fact
you can calculate your own theoretical
maximum heart rate which is heavily
dependent on your age as you grow older
your heart becomes less efficient in
responding to electrical signals and
therefore you will have a lower max
heart rate to calculate it it's 210
beats per minute minus your age so for
me my theoretical max heart rate is
210-30 which puts me at about 180 beats
per minute as for my wife because she
never ages and therefore is still 25 her
theoretical maximum heart rate is 185
beats per minute your max heart rate is
limited by this physiological mechanism
which is good like all proper biological
functions when it works the way it's
supposed to your body functions the way
it should but say there was a defect in
a biological function that caused the
system to operate in a different way
for the heart what if there was a defect
where there was an extra conductive
fiber that connected the upper heart to
the ventricles that would mean that
there's an extra pathway for electrical
signals to reach the ventricles that
shouldn't be there well that's exactly
what happens this extra nerve fiber is
called an accessory pathway and is
actually a congenital birth defect known
as wolf parkinson white syndrome and
occurs in 0.2 percent of the population
what's harmful about this accessory
pathway is it can cause abnormally high
heartbeats known as tachycardia well
above the theoretical 210 beats per
minute when the sa node sends an
electrical signal to the av node this
accessory pathway conducts part of the
signal and it reaches the ventricles
before the normal signal does this
causes the ventricle to contract before
it's supposed to then the regular signal
reaches the ventricle and it contracts
again this birth defect bypasses the
absolute refractory period allowing the
heart to have a much higher limit of how
fast it can beat and as dr emmett brown
said when this baby hits 88 miles per
hour
you're gonna see some serious [ __ ] with
accessory pathways heart rates have been
documented to reach as high as 300 beats
per minute you'd think a condition like
this would be impossible to live with as
the heart would just be out of control
on a daily basis oddly enough that's not
the case most people who have this birth
defect live normal lives because the
condition doesn't manifest until later
in life some may never have an issue at
all however there are exceptions
one famous case involved a 10 year old
named jack searle from cambridge england
in 2018 searle had been born with an
accessory pathway in his heart but it
never manifested as a problem then one
day at school he noticed his heart began
to race for no reason throughout the day
his heart rate increased more and more
causing him to become severely exhausted
and his skin to turn gray due to lack of
blood circulation searle was rushed to
the hospital where his heart rate was
clocked at a staggering 310 beats per
minute which sounds like this
[Music]
doctors noted that had he not been in
the hospital in time he would have
likely died surgeons were able to save
cyril's life by physically extracting
the accessory nerve in his heart it
turns out surgical removal is the most
common solution to accessory pathways
either that or a pacemaker has to be
installed to regulate the electrical
signaling of the heart now you might be
thinking having an incredibly fast heart
rate would be good kind of like a
superpower in theory you'd be able to
breathe and run faster since your heart
is pumping more blood right well it's
quite the opposite the heart is pumping
so fast that almost no blood is getting
into the chambers normally the heart
needs to fill with blood in between
beats sure we're talking microseconds
but each microsecond counts the faster
your heart rate the less time there is
for blood to get in eventually somewhere
around 220 beats per minute your heart
reaches a rate that the chambers open
and close so fast that no blood gets in
if no blood is getting into the heart
firstly you'll faint from lack of oxygen
secondly your heart isn't getting any
oxygen either and so the tissues become
hypoxic heart tissue begins to die and
the heart itself goes into heart failure
it's not a superpower but a fatal
weakness so with empirical evidence we
can say the upper limit of the human
heart rate is 310 beats per minute
however if you're the i want to know the
absolute fastest iron record in history
ever type of person then the fastest in
history is 480 beats per minute or 8
beats per second and sounds like this
[Music]
this specific case was documented in the
year 2000 in the journal of american
cardiology the heartbeat originated from
a human fetus likely with an accessory
pathway deformity a human fetus has a
much higher resting heart rate than a
full grown adult which explains why 480
beats per minute was achievable this
brings us to the last question can your
heart beat so fast that it explodes
no the heart doesn't explode muscle
fibers don't erupt like a pressurized
balloon instead cardiac tissue could
become severely strained and damaged
like any overworked muscle it's possible
if the heart is in tachycardia for too
long muscle fibers could be fatigued to
the point of malfunction which can lead
to blood clots and overall less
efficiency of the heart so yeah that's
the video thanks for watching